yeah welcome to this video um yeah this
video has some said reason actually
because today um really world-class
player died at the yeah rather old age
in middle T of 89 years
this is Vito's ugly girl rich a former
yeah top play and the 50s 60s and 70s of
what was some back then Yugoslavia he
lived in in Serbia in his old age and
Belgrad you grad I'm not quite sure how
to pronounce it yanti he died today and
really leaves behind an enormous amount
of chess games and the wealth of chess
knowledge to to study um yeah I decided
to quickly choose the game to to maybe
present you this really outstanding
player that you might not even know if
you are younger because okay he's died
um 89 years old you can imagine that he
retired from competitive Chesham already
quite a while ago um but he played them
really an enormous amount of instructive
games and in his heyday especially if
you play a 1d for as white he was a very
classical very straightforward player
with deform he also played before but d4
was his son his main move and I was very
very much according to classical star
controlling the center and and so on and
also he was a pioneer of the Kings
Indian defense on which really started
only to gain popularity after the Second
World War it was driven by some Russian
players like um Geller bullies laugh ski
and others but also by a clicker it
should really am picked
immediately after he entered the area of
world-class chess in 1950 or 1951
yeah picked out one game also played in
the Kingston you know this is actually
the game would jump one of the games but
this is the main game
hoo-yeah gave the main line until today
in the main line of the Kings Indian
it's named the model plot a variation
with 91 and on the way we can also show
you a line that is named after Blue
Ridge so let's get going this game is
from 1953 so close to a 60 years old um
and white players we go a night off also
a legend of his own yeah we get the
Kings Indian and the classical variation
yeah at this point click orig himself
invented or developed his own line
Bishop to e3 which until today really is
one of the main weapons that white has
against the King's Indian and for
instance it is regularly played by by
kramnik so ok kramnik is also champion
of the bionet but he plays Bishop III
also also players like gallant Kasparov
in his youth when he mostly played T
foiiowed so played Bishop III so this is
some until now one of the main lines and
a very reliable way for Y to battle the
King's Indian but not if he just
canceled with of course the the main
move until today 9625 97 91 yeah and
this introduces the Mallya plot a
variation which was named yeah after the
the venue where this game was played
mother plot and Argentina so Aggie gorge
played 97 and here white could also play
Bishop e3 which is also yeah a legend
a variation named after legend this is
the cautionary variation but night off
went 493 f5 and here f3 to cover up the
the center and vigorous immediately
played a form to define the pawn
structure Bishop t29 to f6 and here we
have the typical Kings Indian classical
Kings Indian pawn structure with white
having this pawn chain like having this
pawn chain and of course this kind of
wall in the center determines that the
play will be conducted on the flanks
with white going ahead on the on the
Queen side with c5 opening up the C file
and in general playing on the Queen side
and black of course with this g5 and h5
this looks totally normal nowadays but
of course we now have 60 years of
practical experience with this but back
then this position was really young or
this kind of position was really fresh
because until the Second World War let's
say up to 1950 or something they mostly
thought that what d4 means the Queen's
Gambit and there's nothing much else if
you look at for instance the 11 type of
Blanc and match they played the Queen's
Gambit in all the games except one on if
you look at some other games at the time
it was mostly d4 d5 and the King's
Indian was really a brand new concept in
a way alright so here night off plate B
form which nowadays with all this
experience gathered it's known to be
young and and somewhat less exact move
the point is that it probably loses a
bit of time to play this move the main
idea of playing before in the King's
Indian
in this kind of structure is to support
the c5 advance and in fact here he could
have played c5 immediately normally if
you go for this kind of setup you you
don't move the pawn so early you might
move them later but first things first
you need to open up the c4 at first and
then see about the other pieces so c5 is
now established as the mainline it might
continue something like this g5 roxy one
night here and in fact nowadays the
fashionable way to play this even to not
capture here but to play Knight b5 Luke
f7 and Bishop a5 this is the modern
mainline but modern means it was only
discovered like and now three four or
five years ago that this idea of
delaying the capture on d6 might be good
for white yeah but okay we are back in
1953 a knight of plate before g5 and c5
so he is going for c5 after all this is
clear but he may be lost a bit of time
with this before move and h5 to support
the g4 move yam Knight to f3 this is a
typical way to protect the g4 square and
to make it more difficult for black to
pushes at 1 cm it also of course defends
the King Knight to g6 Roxy 1 so it's a
pretty normal position besides the fact
that white is played this before me
rook f7 this is some yeah now a
customary maneuver to protect the 7th
rank here the c7 square in particular
where white might try to invade and it
also clears the way for this Bishop f8
rookie 7 maneuver all this was brand new
back then so it's rather ingenious to
think about the sedative that they
developed all this at the time this was
really young and just was far less
explored and it was lots of really
pioneering work to be done
so night off now took on g6 recapture
and a form yeah okay the Sun once you've
played before you might as well go a
four as well his ideas to push the the a
pond even further to create weaknesses
black continues with this maneuver
Bishop FA to to clear the some place for
the rock and black completes this
maneuver yeah h3 to protect this and
yeah now we have a positional White has
played three pawn moves here on the
Queen side and very often in similar
lines wait didn't do that um he already
has spent time for other things which
might be useful like moving this night
away play a rook to c3 e to defend the
third-ranked other moves and it's not so
clear that this pawn moves really do do
so much good at the moment okay and then
in this point him grigorash plays
another very interesting move Knight h8
and this is really kind of yeah
revelation to to to draw the knight back
all the way to age eight it wasn't
strictly necessary to to do this at at
this moment like could have played g4
immediately it was interesting um for
example something like this just showing
the general IDM something like this
would give like a very nice play along
the G file and ok white could could give
a check here but this Queen might be in
trouble also
it doesn't have much squares let's say
route g6 at some point and the Queen
wouldn't have a square at all
so um this g4 move was also interesting
what can defend better this is just a
just a sample line to illustrate the
general idea but in the game he played
this Knight H eighteenth and this is
really interesting um this Knight
of course it's not planning to stay on
h8 all the time the ideas that night to
have seven and I - oops not there that
night - f7 and night to h6 can be
helpful maneuver to support G for even
more or to recapture pawn on g4 or
Knight f7 to g5 even could be an idea so
the knight is very flexible on this in
this on this ruled on f7 to h6 or to g5
and this is really a great maneuver
which can be used in some other similar
position in the in the Kings in Ian's in
fact them a couple of years ago I had a
game myself and the German liqui I was
able to play this as well and was very
nice to put the knight in the corner and
it's still a good move okay not b5 now
but well it doesn't really threaten
anything at the moment so I'm like
proceeds with G form and yeah what what
should why do him he cannot tolerate
this pawn he needs to needs to capture
and I think it's also better to to let
the pieces on the board here if you
would actually play something like this
maybe not not f7 immediately yeah first
kick this back kick the knight back and
then something along along these lines
would pick up the g4 pawn with a really
strong attack
this somehow makes it easier for black
to - um yeah - it once on the kingside
so we took twice with the pawn and now
first a six getting rid of the snide 9 2
a 3 and Bishop d7 completing the
development in a way and also planning
another quite quite nice maneuver yeah
you know what went which night to a c4
of course this was the point of of this
this route - at the end get to the
weekend b6 square which very often can
be a problem for black Fe in the this
process and needs to yeah allow an
exchange of his light squared bishop
this wouldn't be so um problematic here
even because this bishop is of course
instrumental in blacks play when it
comes to prepare for g4 but in this
position he actually already managed to
play g4 so if this Bishop on d7 gets
exchanged it's not such a big problem in
comparison to two other situations and
the classical Kings Indian but still in
this game he preferred to keep it let's
see what happened rook c8 here
Knight to be six yeah and here just
exchanging on c1 and now Bishop to be
eight and this is really a nice maneuver
this keeps this Bishop on the board but
also intense this nice regrouping when
the bishop on g6 actually would put
pressure on the e4 pawn so a very nice
regrouping and really original way to
play getting this bishop and this the
exact cause to put pressure on e4 all
not very nicely played by black he he
had alternatives he could
also consider to immediately go for this
this route to the g4 pond it's just to
show that you can actually afford to to
give up this this Bishop so this kind of
line is some is pretty okay for black
let's say something like this something
like this at first I thought this might
be good for white but it's not so easy
at all
black might attend this move and one
very important point is if you play rook
c3 analysis then this is very annoying
f3 move with this consequence and at the
end black will attack the weakened pawns
so just to show that the LightSquared
bishop is not so essential in this
position but this this what this
maneuver that vigorish played with
bishop to agents um and I think stronger
and also the far more original way to
play to actually give this bishop a
useful role in the game so I'm not
Bishop to a3 I don't really like the
smooth to be honest it in a way tries to
get to yeah d6 making some pressure here
but it also some arm moves away this
piece from yeah possible defensive
purposes on the Kings side and it also
yeah actually it's a weak yeah but it
can be attacked we see this later but
I'm not quite sure how wide should play
it's um it's not a very comfortable
position maybe this is still okay but
Knight to have seven and now Queens the
two I think white wasn't slight trouble
before but Queen c2 ISM it's not the
best really I think one idea could be
going to be three here
so that after Knight h6 with this idea
of just taking the pawn you have Queen
to h3
and can actually cover this point from
the side and also attack the the night
if black now retreats to f7 then white
couldn't I mean it's very very stupid in
a way to just retreat but it would be it
would be a kind of draw um if black gum
complies black could continue of course
you play at something like rook g6 but
this wouldn't really work so well with
this Bishop idea and white would
continue the game and I think I like
black but it's not like white is losing
or something I think this would have
been a tougher defense
okay Queen c2 and now as planned this
Knight move to get back on the pawn yeah
what would what should Y do now it's
it's really a problem
black will get a good good position
anyway if you want to cover this you
will actually need to put the Queen back
which doesn't make much sense if you
just have played Queen c2 but okay just
to show what would happen like would
actually play the somewhat strange move
Bishop b5 exchanging off this Bishop and
then you would get to g4 finally the
position like this is especially funny
looking at this very stupid piece and
this stupid piece
they are both far away from doing
anything meaningful and black will crash
through on the on the G file next I
think this is really a huge advantage
already for black one idea could be
something like this let's say Y
jettisons the pawn and returns then this
kind of ideas almost close to winning so
black has fine position yay play g5 may
be irritating this pieces a bit okay
black just recaptured this
and now look see one may be trying to
get something on the C file or maybe
play rook c3 to cover on the
third-ranked
but now comes look to g3 and this is
what I meant this bishop really is yeah
bit of a liability on a3 it really
didn't do much good and yeah now you see
that this move is even a problem yeah it
played this should be two back and now
Knight to g4 all very logical getting
the the Knights into play
yeah why to exchange everything off I
think you cannot tolerate any peace no
your king for example just just to show
if he wouldn't take here let's say white
would place a mother move um let's say
getting the knight back to to defend
then you've got this coming
threatening Queen h2 with checkmate to
come and this is terrible with f3 coming
up and Dwight simply a.m. has no defense
to this so you need to get rid of this
night Ruby form and Queen f2 yeah one
alternative here that he served in check
term what Quincy aid in fact them
this is answered by the strong move
Queen g5 not especially difficult to
find but so nice just immediately
getting on the g2 pawn if white now take
this Bishop which was sacrificed then
black can just take on g2 into f1 and
then the simple move the simple not
really but yeah the the the silent move
rook to h2 and yeah White has no way to
prevent me TM can nothing to give one
check or some
but Koenji - is impossible - to avoid or
other mating patterns coming up so um
this Quincy aid idea didn't really help
this is why ya move the Queen and the
direction of the king to help defending
note that this Knight is simply offside
and now Bishop d6 and this shows this
really ingenious idea Bishop e8 to g6
attacking now the weak pawn on e4 white
covered this pond and black played Queen
e7 and this is really really nice the
ideas he wants to go to h7 attacking the
spawn again and then h7 look to here
rook to h4 and then along the edge file
so it's just very very yeah
aesthetically pleasing how I played this
Bishop d3 I mean what doesn't really
have anything it's a this position is
already beyond any saving Queen age 7
yes mentioned this was the idea
Queen e2 to cover this and now rook to
h4 and White has no way to prevent this
look - to come to h1 he moved the king
and how black cam has a very nice move
it all fits very much into the flow of
this game played now the very strong
move f3 and this is quite nice because
the pawn cannot be taken with with any
piece if you are we can go through this
do you capture here the Queen gets lost
check this also wins the Queen and King
f3 and maybe there's a mate even just
but this would win the Queen also so
white cannot capture needs to go here
yeah and now there's more than one
winning move he played one of them
look to have form threatening to take
you with check and also threatening the
Queen to clean flattening with the Queen
to come to age form yeah white took
check and now black entered with the
Queen Queen edge to check ok and now all
pieces join the attack
Bishop age 5 completely this nice zigzag
route attacking f3 and white cannot
defend this he just he continued king he
to rook takes f3 Shia White has got one
revenge check and he had played King c2
he could have played them I can really
show this he played another check but
it's it's simply just one check and here
it's just over no more checks and next
black will actually get a real attack
compared to just a couple of checks so
um this wouldn't have helped he went
king c2 and now okay f2 check you should
be too strong Queen d1 check King c3 ha
and Queen a1 Czechia and white resigned
there's thus simply nothing you can do
for instance King to be three years
answered by this neat check on d1 and
yeah black gum black will get get
through here something like this just
just wins the house and maybe it should
it should be made really I didn't look
too closely but it at least Windsor
almost all pieces yeah a very very nice
game which really showed the other
positive sides and maneuvers that are
associated with this mainline Kings
Indian what we now know as the modded
plot a variation but whoops what really
was they're kind of invented in this
game just just a side note of course the
the times are completely bogus like
usual
Isis he just sets his two minutes stuff
of course it was a real five hour long I
guess tournament game yeah okay yeah I
said I said way somehow to to do a video
sort of in memoriam video but yeah while
the games are still live on and I think
it's very useful to use those those
classical games to look at typical
maneuvers and ideas and sort of in a way
sometimes understand the historical
background of those kind of lines and
strategical ideas behind those openings
for instance this move before which now
it's really known to be slightly in
exact as a move which is commonly played
so on by amateur players even stronger
amateur players played this kind of
stuff against the Kingston yeah and it's
really it's really a second-rate way to
do it but if you look at all these games
and learn how this line-to-line
progressed over the years um yeah we
will really improve your understanding
and strategical knowledge of this kind
of position so it's very useful to to
yeah get to know the historical
backgrounds of those games back from
sixty years ago you can still learn from
these games and see that for instance
this kind of move and this kind of set
up that white chosen the following it's
not the best
yes study Digga richest games he's a
very good role model in a way for for
playing chess especially his d4 games
for instance in the names of Indian and
and against the green fat and so on
they're really young there's a ton of
classic classic games and I really could
have chosen a ton of games to show ya
just picked one that that came to mind
for instance he beat Bobby Fischer I
think four or five times or so so
Fischer had a positive record overall
but he lost like four or five games to
bigger rich these were also interesting
yeah thanks for watching this game and
yeah talk to you soon with new videos